[Música]
ah
es una herramienta que nos ayuda a
transformar la realidad
cuando aceptamos dejamos de ver esa
porción de realidad que no nos gusta que
está mal que no debería estar pasando
que yo no quiero que esté
para contextualizarlas y cuando lo
contextualizamos podemos ver que además
de una fracción que no nos gusta hay
otras opciones
con la ampliación del programa tenemos
además entonces la capacidad de elegido
y cuando elegimos accionamos y cuando
accionamos transformamos
y estoy diciendo aceptar y no digo
tolerar ni resistir porque tolerancia y
resistencia
o resignación implican resistencia
y lo que resiste persiste
entonces la aceptación es una llave que
nos pueda seguir de la impotencia
[Música]
esto que escuchamos es la alarma del
respirador de mi hijo bruno
luego nació hace casi ya dos años con
una miopatía congénita esto es una
enfermedad muscular que hace que tenga
muy poca fuerza y sus músculos
como los pulmones tienen fibra muscular
le cuesta sostener la respiración
entonces está traqueostomizado y con un
respirador
el día de la cesárea de bruno de nación
durante la cirugía yo escuchaba a un
doctor
yo sabía esto no no no van a buscar otro
otro era otro tacho para el líquido
amniótico porque había demasiado y nadie
lo sabía el interior que en el ínterin
que la enfermera va a buscar ese tacho
bruno prada el líquido amniótico y al
tratarlo así me pocs ya sea se queda sin
oxígeno en el cerebro
y hace un paro
terminó en la cirugía el neonatólogo me
lo muestra de lejos a bruno me dice este
tu hijo mamá nos lo llevamos ya para
estabilizarlo anel y se fueron estos
pues las dos y media de la tarde eran
las siete y nadie sabía nada
ningún médico vino explicarme nada los
enfermeros lo único que sabía era que
estaba en la neo la familia obviamente
todos con cara de circunstancia no
querían saberlo lo poco o nada que sabía
a las 7 de la tarde no aguanté más me
levanté de la cama como pude para darle
el suero y en camisón nos pidió al sexto
piso que es el escaneo y pedí ver a mi
hijo
me dijeron que no porque estaba muy
grave
entonces me llamo un médico aparte y me
explicó que algo que había sucedido
durante la cesárea me lo mostró a través
de un vidrio
cómo aceptarse
el otro día lo pudo entrar a ver a la
semana lo pude tener en brazos y a
medida que pasaron los días y las
semanas me di cuenta que esto no era
grave era gravísimo porque no sólo bruno
estaba entubado sin fuerza lejos de mí
sino que además los médicos no sabían ni
cómo había pasado ni que tenía ni que
hacer al respecto es más no sabían si
derivarlo porque no sabían si iba a
tolerar los dos las dos horas de viaje
en aviones
de nuevo una mezcla de emociones y de
impotencia y miedo y susto y angustia
se apoderaron de mí
entonces me di cuenta que nadie estaba
haciendo nada y que la única que podía
hacer algo era yo
por lo cual lo primero que hice fue
recurrir a instrumentos que yo traigo
desde mi juventud que son la respiración
consciente y la meditación para poder
mantenerme en eje dentro de las
circunstancias en la jienense esto era
lo más alejado a la fantasía que yo
tenía de como ya comenzar mi vida como
mamá
entonces todos los días 6 y media de la
mañana nos dejaban entrar a ver alguno a
las 10 así que yo seis y media me
levantaba me bañaba hacía respiración
meditaba y con esa tranquilidad dentro
de lo que cabe me ponía a llamar por
teléfono o mandar mails y whatsapp o
contactar allí acá para ver cómo
podíamos sacar a bruno de acá y llevarlo
a un lugar donde le pudieran hacer
estudios si tuviéramos llegar a un
diagnóstico para comenzar un tratamiento
tardamos dos meses y finalmente lo
logramos a los dos meses pudimos viajar
a buenos aires el mono serios estuvimos
seis meses más imagínense si estuve
trabajando la aceptación primero estuvo
un mes en neonatología luego otro
especializaron luego estuvimos en
terapia intermedia
entonces trabajando todos los de la
aceptación no pude más que además de
hacer mucha introspección darme cuenta
que cada vez que yo había aplicado esto
de aceptar mi vida se ha transformado
recapitulando y atrás en mi vida y por
ejemplo en mi adolescencia ya un
adolescente muy adolescente con un combo
completo de depresión bulimia anorexia
intento de suicidio así
y claro en un punto
de este hangar empecé a estar mareada la
presión baja medio descompuesta todo el
tiempo y eso es me funcionó como alarma
no esto no está bien está bien
obviamente yo no comía y lo pongo que
comía lo vomitaba estaba todo el tiempo
con la presión con el piso pero bueno a
mí me funcionó de alarma para decir y en
lo que no estoy haciendo bien
y busque ayuda
si pueblo me vio y para ayudarme a
modificar los trastornos de alimenticios
me hizo ver que ya no sólo era esto que
a mí no me gustaba de micro mis caderas
sino que además en un cuerpo entero y
además del cuerpo entero tenía otra
facilidad otras capacidades tenían esa
sonrisa tenía mi capacidad intelectual
tenían mi forma de amar
era un como mucho más grande que esto
que a mí no me gustaba
fue remontar esta circunstancia del
trastorno de alimento pasaban los años
me fui a estudiar a buenos aires allí di
vale por un montón de carreras porque
todas son nomás cerradas no me gustaba
parecen aburridas superficiales la
cuestión que yo todavía no encontraba
que hacer y paralelamente trabajaba en
trabajos que no me gustaban hacer porque
el arte de marketer pero tenía que
estudiando así que tenía que estás
bancando me en la carrera
llegó un momento que claro empecé
nuevamente a no estar feliz y volvía a
mis comportamientos autodestructivos
llegando a un último intento de suicidio
cuando me despierto
miro a mi alrededor
estaba en una clínica psiquiátrica
divina topísima de barrio norte pero una
clínica psiquiátrica y miro mis compis
de locura era una señora que se había
tirado debajo de un tren le faltaba un
bracito
una chica que se estaba recuperando de
alcoholismo así que estaba con una
botellita debajo del brazo por las
esquinas una señora que no quería vivir
más tapada hasta arriba super de tris
depresión deprimida como que de hecho
acá como que de ello acá
mis elecciones o mi falta de elección
fueron lo que me trajo hasta este punto
y vi claramente todas mis debilidades
todos mis errores todas las faltas pero
vi una gran fortaleza que es que había
sobrevivido a mí misma
y esto me empoderó entonces me puse las
pilas y en siete días me dieron el alta
de la clínica psiquiátrica y créanme que
siete días para una clínica psiquiátrica
privada es muy poco tiempo así que
efectivamente este está este
empoderamiento que viene a través de la
aceptación da resultado luego mejoré mi
vida y me fiesta me fui a vivir a europa
y viaje y tuve las aventuras más locas
más bizarras más divertidas hasta ese
momento más intensas pero también llegó
un punto en el que empecé a entrenarme
criaba presión baja no estaba bien
claramente no andaba bien no estaba
haciendo felices una ciudad desde
suponía que tendría que estar re
contenta vivía en barcelona y un trabajo
recopa do y sin embargo yo no estaba
feliz entonces nuevamente acepté que yo
no estaba siendo feliz en este lugar
donde se suponía que yo debería estar
bien no estaba feliz extrañaba a mi
familia que quería venir a ver a mi mamá
a mi papá y amigos sobrinos y toda la
gente que se todo en la nueva generación
que vienen venía de familia
acepte eso lo contextualizó y las
opciones y en seis meses estaba de nuevo
en argentina en buenos aires sino en
comodoro tan comodoro desarrolle una
carrera profesional que fue la propia
superdivertido estuvo muy bien y se hizo
un montón de cosas muy divertidas hasta
que nació crono tal como les contaba al
principio
llega a bruno con todo este nuevo bagaje
de realidad y cuando volvimos de buenos
aires
ahí hay fue loco hay por loco de verdad
porque no solo mi hijo está con esta
enfermedad track estilizado con un
respirador sino que además tenía que
lidiar con el ideal con 24 horas tengo
esencia con 24 horas de enfermería
porque tenemos internación domiciliaria
proveedores terapistas toda la gente
entrando y saliendo de mi casa todo el
tiempo perdiendo un poco la intimidad un
poco no bastante pero bueno es algo con
lo que uno estas cosas es en el fuero
íntimo y uno como puede con las
herramientas que tiene las va a resolver
no porque suceden adentro de tu casa y
las resuelves
lo difícil al menos para mí ha sido
la mirada social no cuando salís a la
calle y te das cuenta que las rampas
para discapacitados están tapadas cuando
sacó el celular y muestro a mi hijo
porque me preguntan y también de cómo
está usar con se lo digo bien / bien
porque no puedo sacarlo a la calle
conmigo
y la mirada de lástima del otro es muy
fuerte ya cuando porque además mi hijo
está muy bien es un luchador yo tengo la
bendición de poder decir que con dos
años casi dos años sostengo la certeza
que mi hijo es un guerrero y no sé
cuántos padres tienen esa bendición ese
sitial con esa mirada es un poco hasta
chocante y así con muchas otras cosas
más porque también está
la falta de ética la falta de compromiso
o la falta de muchas carencias que
tenemos a nivel social busquen un
espacio entonces para poder poder
compartir todo esto con otros padres no
lo encontré entonces entre las opciones
elegí crear un grupo un encuentro para
padres con hijos fuera de la norma con
hijos con enfermedades severas con hijos
con enfermedades crónicas con
internación domiciliaria donde nos
encontramos guiados por un psicólogo
social
podemos hacer catarsis descargarnos
aprender de la experiencia de los otros
porque en realidad eso es lo que nos
pasamos al poder pero que se puede ver
cómo se puede por que transitarlo como
les decía se tiene que transitar y uno
lo va resolviendo como puede pero con la
experiencia del otro es mejor entonces
la aceptación no solo te modifica a vos
sino que además puede modificar tu
entorno porque formamos parte de un
sistema y en los sistemas cuando se
modifica una cosa se modifica todo
yo digo aceptar y estoy hablando a
partir de que aceptamos pero como
llegamos a la aceptación
cada cual tiene su forma de navegar y
atravesar las tormentas pero hay un
punto en el que esa realidad que no está
bien que está mal que no quiere es que
no debería ser que es injusta incluso es
tan contundente que te aplasta y allí
tenéis dos opciones o te quedas debajo
aplazado o te movés y poder generar el
canal
a mí
me sirve escucharme cuando mi cuerpo me
dice lo que hasta acá puedes resistir
hasta acá soportas tenés que hacer algo
yo me escucho porque mi cuerpo es muy
claro
y vos
cuál es tu alarma para empezar a
transformar tu realidad
[Música]
ah
y